hello again
we some people deny that uh
aikido and all the martial arts to my
knowledge
except maa and bjj
seem to be in decline
and i've talked about this before
and i think we need a new generation not
the dinosaurs like myself
you know been there enjoyed every second
of it
with them every second but enjoyed most
and we've always done the warm-ups
you know preparation of the body i think
we need to re-package
the way we we get
new people and keep them
a lot of the clubs who need to survive
dojos people who are
doing it full time
they usually take on children's classes
because that's
where you get big numbers that brings in
the money
if we can have a new generation
of teachers
i had to learn i was given the class at
brown belt
and i was teaching from
fourth queue so rambert's first cue
anybody who has doesn't have colored
belts
and i had to learn made many mistakes
still sometimes come away from the
seminar thinking
oh perhaps i should have said this or
perhaps i should have handled it that
way
so it's a a lifelong learning curve
but i think we need to look at
what we can offer the people today
because martial arts i think help to
forge the person
to become something that they don't know
what they're going to be
they come as what they think they want
out of it
and they may if they keep doing it long
enough
end up completely a different person
i know my jane she has said from time to
time
he's a completely different person to
the person i first met
i hope for the better
so i think we should repackage
what we're doing
we can you can mix up the variations
if we were to do 15 to 20 minutes
of yoga or
something where it will slowly ease the
body
but allow the body to have a long-term
memory
of what we're doing and a repetition
of this week after week perhaps say for
the month
perhaps the aikidoka could if they don't
want to do it themselves or they don't
feel that they're knowledgeable enough
to talk to
to a local fitness trainer
a yoga teacher
you know spend a few
hours going around looking to see what
you think
of people who are teaching fitness
aerobics anything that is to do with
caring for the body freeing up the
joints
gentle stretching vigorous works out
i mean each
each individual who's teaching aikido
in this case
they can't go against their own
personality and their desires or what
they think
aikido is
and most classes have an hour and a half
somewhere too and it appears to be the
maximum
students want when we done our survey
so my hope is
for the future that aikido will even
being a niche
art it will survive
it's never been great it's always been
low in numbers we've always wanted more
students
as soon as you get students you lose
students you keep some
they get to downgrade they think that
that's where they want to go
they leave they had that in their mind
all the time
i'll just work towards my black mouth
that's all i want to do to be able to
say that i've got a black guy in aikido
people are very strange and my mind
doesn't
factor in strange things
i'm strange enough as it is
i try to think logically you know if i
see
somebody with a black t-shirt
i wouldn't say i like your pink t-shirt
they think i'm
an idiot wouldn't they if i say
oh that's a nice black t-shirt what's
the writing sign it
i'm saying things that are logical
so people come into aikido
they first see the advert aikido
japanese martial i
haven't got a clue what it means unless
they've researched it
so let's stop putting on the banners
aikido
japanese martial art beginners classes
you might as well say
well i don't know but you might as well
say something completely
alien if you're trying to reach the
public
hide aikido somewhere in the body of the
advert
not plaster it across them
put in a beginner's class
in well-being and fitness
this is how i think you're not conning
anybody you're not
telling them what they're not going to
get but if you repackage it
so we have 15 to 20 minutes
of yoga or some kind of fitness
stretching
bodybuilding but not in a muscular way
because muscles tend to restrict
the flow of aikido and you need to have
a more supple
and relaxed body than a tensed one or a
muscle-bound one
if you tell the people before they come
what they're going to get
then they'll know they're going to get
15 to 20 minutes
of yoga or fitness
show that it will be followed then
by the master the teacher
of technical aikido
what is considered a japanese art
of self-defense with locks
of joints and explain that
and then explain that the last
five to ten minutes would be a warm down
on what the class was appropriate
early balanced
so if it's a weapons class you would do
you still need to stretch just because
it weapons and you're standing doesn't
the body will still be tense and stiff
perhaps even more so because of the
concentration so i believe it should be
done in every single class
then have say an hour of
aikido weapons or tajitsu
and then a 10 minutes warm down
might just be swinging the can lightly
or doing hypogeary
we we try to a lot of you perhaps will
do this already but try to make
your aikido clubs and dojos more of a
family environment
and not a strict martial environment
i remember one sensei making all the
students
line up outside the dojo when they went
and came they would have to know when
they're coming they'd have to look out
and they'd all stand there ready
slightly head bowing
these days to me i believe are gone
we can still teach technical good
strong aikido
it's a martial art whatever you may
think
you may think that it has to become more
like a dance
more spiritual more harmonious
but we're talking about people who are
in everyday life with stresses and
strains
that need to unwind
some will want to learn the marshall
side but we have to take care of them
in many years that come like me now at
70.
my body is still ok my knees are shot
because i was a motor mechanic all my
life
kneeling on concrete but they were shot
when i was in my
30 32 i believe
the surgeon said you have osteoarthritis
in your knees give up aikido or you'll
be in a wheelchair by the time you're
50.
well i'm still here at 70 no wheelchair
and it's because i decided
that all this scaremongering meant that
i needed to start looking after my body
think about yourself hopefully we've all
got a long
long life and just being good at aikido
but being replacement knees and hips
when you're in your 60s
but to say that you really enjoyed
aikido isn't
going to to me be a worthwhile
thing to have done you do it as a hobby
it may become a way of life
it has become for me as many of you i'm
sure
but don't wreck yourself through it
and you as teachers don't wreck the
people that entrust themselves with you
please consider making aikido more
of a family where you take care of
people this is no sense his dream i
think
for us to love one another care for one
another
and to me people don't
like to stretch bend do excise
the people who have been in my era
wanted to get down to the aikido they
didn't want to do
preparation just you know been working
hard all day
let's just get on with the aikido to me
these times have gone we're not samurais
we're human beings
we can become very good martial artists
as long as we have common sense know
that
it's also important to live
a good life bring up a family do all the
things that you have to do
outside of aikido as well as
training in the art thank you for
listening
please subscribe if you're enjoying
these
thank you